Good morning, Hank. It's Sunday.
so the Yeti and I are beginning this "gigantor" home renovation,
part of which is to replace these moldy basement walls with like non-moldy basement walls.
And when the contractor came in to talk to us about it,
he was like: "Look, I recommend destroying the wall on your own.
I mean it takes a professional to build a wall, but anybody can demolish a wall."
And now, Hank, a week later, I feel like I can say with authority and pride that
if anyone can demolish a wall, I can do something that no one can do: fail at demolishing a wall.
And so, today, Hank, I'm going to share my unique talent with you.
I am going to teach you how NOT to demolish a wall in six easy steps.
Step one: the Octopus
So, Hank, my first strategy to try to tear down the wall --
this was pre-holes, by the way -- was to throw myself against it.
I did this once before, actually, I threw myself against the wall to find out if I was an octopus
because, you know, octopi stick to walls but people don't.
And when I did it that first time I felt the wall shake a little, so the first thing I tried was the octopus.
[sound of John hitting the wall] [John groans]
Gah
Still not an octopus.
So that didn't work. Then I moved on to step two: calling former Soviet Leader Mikhail Gorbachev.
"Oh, hi Mr. Gorbachev? Tear down that wall!"
And he was like, "Shto? Shto? Ya ne govario po anglisky. (What? What? I do not speak English.)"
You know, and then, of course I remember he doesn't speak English, and plus he lives in Russia,
so it'd be like totally expensive to find Indiana just to tear down my basement wall...
and so I moved on to step 3: calling Dad.
Dad said I needed a crowbar, but I felt like crowbars are like handguns, you know?
I understand that I have a constitutional right to own a crowbar,
but I don't really feel like I need one unless I'm a career criminal.
But he eventually convinced me to go out and buy a crowbar, whereupon, I commenced with step four:
attempting to use a crowbar.
[sounds of the crowbar against the wall]
[John letting out sounds of frustration]
Which went like that for about an hour and a half. Then, I moved on to step 5:
getting really angry, which is where the holes in the wall that you see come into play.
Basically, Hank, I got really mad and I started to hit the wall, which I don't mean metaphorically.
[yelling out of frustration]
HULK SMASH
Then I did that until I felt sleepy, whereupon, I took a nap.
And then, when I woke up I moved on to step six,
which if you're going to NOT demolish a wall you'll want to save until the very end of your experience.
Step six is checking to make sure
there is no active electrical wiring in the places where you are willy-nilly throwing your steel crowbar.
Which as it turns out, there is.
So that's how you DON'T demolish a wall. You do the Octopus, you call Mikhail Gorbachev,
you call your dad, you get a crowbar, you go bonkers, you take a nap, you wake up from the nap
check for electrical wiring, and then declare yourself a proud and epic fail.
Oh home renovation, you have begun so auspiciously.
Hank, you'll see me on Tuesday
But will you see the wall? Only time will tell.
So, Hank, I think when you get a crowbar,
you're supposed to want to like smash stuff with it, but that wasn't my initial reaction.
My first reaction was that I wanted to treat it as a cane and kind of do a dance?
Like... do do do do do do do do
Do do do do do do do do do do do!